PHILLIP GREENSPUN:
All right, we're
going to talk about
aircraft performance, which
is figuring out
all of this stuff
if you're an
airplane, basically,
how much runway you're
going to use on both ends,
how long it's going to
take you to get there,
which is another way of
saying how much fuel you're
going to use.
If it's a helicopter, it's
a little bit different.
Mostly, you're worried
about hover performance.
So if you're going
to a friend's house,
are you going to be able to
park the helicopter in midair--
that's called an out of
ground effect hover--
and very slowly descend into
the backyard, dodging the trees
and power lines
and anything else?
So these are all
things that can be
found in the aircraft manuals.
And the FAA will test
you on them a little bit.
This is important
partly because you
want to be able to complete your
flight safely, and also because
of FAR 91.103, which is
that, before you do a flight,
you've got to become a--
it's pretty all-embracing,
all-available information
concerning weather, and aircraft
performance, how the aircraft's
going to perform given the
altitude of where you're going,
and the temperature that's
prevailing there at the time.
Wind also, you know?
If you find out that there's
a 40 knot wind scheduled
for where you're going and
it's a direct crosswind
to the only runway,
then that might
to cause you to choose
a different airport.
OK, here's a reminder
of the thrust and drag.
Whenever you're
generating lift, you're
also generating some drag.
And that's lifting the unwanted
direction of backwards,
usually.
So the aircraft is also
producing a parasitic drag
by trying to punch its way
through this vicious fluid
of air.
Where these summed
up drag curves
intersect is pretty
much the bottom
of the total drag curve, the
minimum drag, or L over D max.
The climb performance,
the best speeds to go
are all kind of tied
into this drag curve.
And the best angle of
climb is what you use.
That's a slower airspeed
and the best rate of climb.
If you're in a small
airport, trying
to clear the trees at
the end of the runway,
you're going to fly Vx,
the best angle of climb.
This is one of
those few V speeds
that you're actually expected
to know the abbreviation for.
And if you're going to just
take off out of a big airport,
like Hanscom Field,
and just want
to get up to your cruising
altitude reasonably quickly,
then you--
hey.
Thanks, Richard.
Richard's a Mooney pilot.
Made it to California
many times.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: So if
you actually look at the Vx,
one thing to notice is that it
all depends a bit on the wind.
Let's say there's 100 knot
wind blowing down the runway.
You don't need to fly
very fast in order
to clear the trees at
the end of the runway
because you're basically
already flying.
And you can go straight up
like a helicopter in terms
of your path over the
ground, whereas Vy,
just to gain altitude,
that doesn't depend
at all on the prevailing wind.
So if you're trying to clear
something on the ground,
the wind matters.
A tail tailwind would
be very destructive.
It'll be pushing you
towards the obstacle.
And a headwind will
be very helpful.
Cruise climb, most
of the time you
don't actually push the
airplane to these speeds.
They're pretty
far nose up, which
is a little bit
alarming to passengers.
And it's harder to
see over the nose,
and the engine isn't getting as
much cooling air at these lower
speeds.
So typically we'll fly about 10
knots faster in a GA airplane.
So for the Cirrus, for example,
96 is the book Vy at sea level,
and flying something like 105
knots is more conventional.
The PC-12 climbs--
you know, it might
be able to do 3,000 feet
a minute at 120 knots.
But if you're not
in a desperate hurry
to get up above the bumpy
clouds or something,
then 150 knots is
more conventional.
OK, so let's remember that
you've got thrust and power.
So the thrust is
a force that lets
you climb up over the trees.
The power is thrust
times the speed.
And it's thrust operating
over a period of time.
So the more excess power you
have, the higher the rate
at which you can climb.
Anyway, we'll see some
more of that here.
You've got a best glide ratio.
If you want to get to
the decent place to land
and you've lost your engine,
what's a good speed to fly?
Well, L over D max is an
excellent speed to fly,
because that's where
the lift over drag
is at its highest
point and you'll
make the best time
over the ground.
Again, that has to be adjusted
a little bit for wind.
If you're going into 100
knot wind and the Cirrus best
glide speed is 96
knots, that's not
going to work out very well.
You're not going to go
anywhere over the ground.
That's a photo that I took
at the Newport Jazz Festival.
I don't want to
say self portrait.
Anyway, weight has a huge
factor on all these speeds,
because actually a lot of them
are related to angle of attack.
And it certainly affects
your performance.
So everything about higher
weight is pretty bad.
Wind, you might think that
a tailwind is always good.
But really, the tailwind is only
good for extending your cruise
range.
Everything else, pretty much,
the headwind is better for.
So think about the headwind.
Again, think of
these extreme cases.
If you've got 100 knot
wind right in your face,
then you can fly without moving.
That's basically a wind tunnel.
OK, center of gravity.
This is also a little
bit counterintuitive.
If you load the airplane up so
that all the way to the back,
and it's super
nose up, and you're
having to push the stick
forward to keep the plane level,
that actually is where you
get your maximum performance.
Everything is better about
having an aft center of gravity
with one exception, which is
the stability of the handling
of the aircraft.
And obviously, if you load
it up so much in the back
that you can't
push the nose over,
that would be outside of the
CG range, or well outside
of this range, let's hope.
Then you wouldn't even
be able to control
the aircraft because you can't
get the nose down enough.
So having that forward CG
gives you more stability.
That's where you're going to
be when you're a student pilot.
If you're in a four-seat
aircraft and it's just you
and the instructor in front
and the back seats are empty,
then it's pretty
obvious that it's
going to be a somewhat forward
CG, because the aircraft is
designed to hold at least
some weight in the back seats.
One thing you can do is sort of,
just as a first approximation,
you know, pay attention--
we're going to have a
talk on weight and balance
later from Tina.
But just keep in mind that the
aircraft is kind of designed
for, you know, two
adults in the front
and maybe one adult in the
back, or two kids in the back.
So if you load it
up that way, it's
almost always going to work.
If, on the other hand, you
have a big, heavy friend
and, you know, his other
big heavy friend or his box
of anvils, and the
guy says, well, look,
I just want to
sleep in the back,
I don't want to be up
front and get distracted,
and you're a lightweight
person all by yourself
from the front, you know,
that's the situation where it's
important to really
do the calculations
and think carefully about it.
Because that wasn't something
that Cessna and Piper
were thinking about when
they designed the aircraft.
OK, atmospheric pressure.
Remember we talked
about how the atmosphere
is going to be
expanded when it's hot
and contracted when it's cold?
And the altimeter is
really telling you
how much of the atmosphere
you've climbed up through.
So you can see here on the
right, if you look over here,
and you're measuring
your altitude,
you're basically getting
this whole stack of molecules
contributing to the
pressure, whereas if you're
up high in the
stratosphere or something,
only a handful of molecules are
on top of you putting pressure
into your altimeter.
OK, here's that standard
atmosphere again.
So you can see it's two
niner niner two and 15
degrees at sea level.
So the aircraft performance
is hugely affected by changes
in air density, which themselves
are affected by the prevailing
pressure, which is mostly
a function of altitude,
the temperature,
and the humidity.
Usually, the conditions
are referenced to the ISA,
the standard atmosphere.
The summertime,
it'll be, you know,
ISA plus 15 or ISA plus 20.
And if it's the wintertime, it
might be ISA or ISA minus 20.
When the air density is reduced
and there are fewer molecules
around, the engine is not taking
in as much air for combustion.
Remember that the jet engines
are normally aspirated.
And the piston engines also
that are without a turbocharger,
they're just trying to burn
up a fixed volume of air.
And that's going to correspond
to a different number
of molecules of air and fuel
depending on the altitude.
The only good thing
about going up high--
the propeller's
also not grabbing
as much air for thrust.
The only thing good
about going up high
is that drag is
reduced, and that's
why you see the
airliners up high.
They go faster and they
save a lot of fuel.
OK, some definitions.
The pressure altitude
is just the--
it's going to be your
height above sea level
with the altimeter set
to two niner niner two.
You just have to take
the two niner niner
two minus the actual altimeter
setting that's being published,
multiply that by 1,000, so
a full inch of altimeter
adjustment, from two niner
niner two to three zero
niner two would correspond
to 1,000 foot difference
in pressure altitude.
And you can calculate
that by a chart.
Here's a chart
that they give you
if you don't like the formula.
So this is something, again,
you might have to do on a test.
I'll say, OK, at two nine
niner two, the correction is 0.
At 30.0, the
correction is minus 73.
So up here you can see
we've got this formula where
we interpolated between the
two to try to figure out,
what would the
pressure altitude be
if we start with a
field elevation of 3,563
and the altimeter is two
niner niner six, which is
just a little bit non-standard?
We would expect a
40 foot difference.
If we look at the table
and we interpolate,
we come up with a
36.5 foot difference.
And we find out
that the airplane
feels as though it's only at
3,526 feet above sea level,
assuming the temperature
matches that ISA standard.
All right, so density altitude
is a lot more important.
And oftentimes it will be
reported on the ASOS or ATIS.
So the airport will
actually tell you
density altitude is
3,000 feet or 2,000 feet
or whatever it is.
That you get from
correcting what's usually
a relatively small correction
for pressure altitude compared
to the actual altitude,
but correcting it
for the non-standard
temperature.
I think, as I said
earlier, you know,
flying is a lot more popular in
New England in the summertime
than in the wintertime, so it's
usually warmer than standard.
Density altitude has a
huge effect on performance.
And it's a non-linear
relationship,
so you have to look
it up in a table
or calculate it with the E6B.
We'll see.
Maybe I'll play
around with the E6B
so people can look
at it during breaks.
I have the slide rule and
the manual right here.
And I think we'll try to get
the document camera going,
so maybe I can show you
guys some exciting slide
rule activities.
OK, so you can calculate
it, though, using the E6B,
like I said, using charts.
And there's various web
and app way of doing it.
So the density altitude,
here's a chart.
So again, this is
the kind of stuff
that's on the written exam.
You guys are all pretty good at
working with charts and tables,
so I'm sure you won't
have any trouble.
They're giving you these
initial conditions up here
on your left.
So you look to find
where the pressure
altitude is on the chart.
And it says to, you
know, add 626 feet, which
is interpolating
between those two.
Then you've got this
pressure altitude
line of going from here
down to here at 5,856.
And now we've got to correct
that for temperature.
So here's our temperature of
about 80 degrees, 81 degrees.
And then we go over to the
left, and we can read that--
I think I told you guys
that, in the summertime,
usually the density altitude
is about 2,000 feet higher
than the pressure altitude.
And sure enough,
here it's 8,250,
which is about 2,400 feet higher
than the pressure altitude.
So the density altitude gave us
a little more than a 2,000 foot
boost for that
non-standard temperature.
The reason it's so much,
I guess, is it's not--
80 degrees at sea
level wouldn't be
that high above the
standard temperature.
But 81 degrees Fahrenheit
at a mile above sea level
is quite a spectacular
temperature compared
to the standard atmosphere.
Let's go back to the
standard atmosphere.
Yeah, so at 5,000
feet, it's only
supposed to be seven
degrees Celsius.
And here we said it was
about 27 degrees Celsius.
So that's ISA plus 20.
Just like I said, if you look
at a lot of jet performance
charts, you have ISA minus
20 ISA and ISA plus 20.
Oh, flight computer
demo if there's time.
Let me just futz with that
at the end of all this.
I'll give you an E6B intro.
When are they the same?
I think this is an FAA test
question, when the temperature
distribution is the same as
that of the standard atmosphere.
OK, humidity is also another
enemy, a little bit more
surprisingly.
The water vapor molecules,
actually, in the air
actually reduce the
density of the air.
You might think that
they would increase it.
I don't know.
Maybe there's a chemist or a
physicist in this crowd who
can explain why.
I'm not exactly sure myself.
But it's just something to
remember, that contrary--
if the air feels
heavy to you, it
feels light to your aircraft
engine and to your wings.
It's a smaller effect
than temperature,
but the engine
performance supposedly
can be reduced by about 7%.
This is not something that
we normally correct for.
However, there is this
nice web calculator
that I found for free
on pilotfriend.com.
And you get to enter the
relative humidity of the air.
So where is that?
We have the air temperature.
Oh, we have the
dew point, right?
So we said it was a 30 degree
temperature and a 28 degree dew
point.
So that's a pretty
narrow spread.
And therefore, it's a
pretty high humidity day.
So they say, well,
it's 78% humidity,
and we're correcting
that up to 8,107.
You can play around
with this on your own.
If you reduce the dew point
to 10 degrees Celsius,
which is going to
be a really dry--
you know, 30 to 10 split
is a nice, dry day out west
or, you know, here
occasionally a crisp day--
then it's only 7,735.
So the change in humidity
had about a 300-foot effect
on the altitude.
But the change in temperature
was nearly 3,000 feet.
OK, the maximum convenience
way to do this is with apps.
So ForeFlight, for example,
will just tell you.
The density altitude--
this was, I think,
Sunday night at Bedford.
Let's look at this beautiful--
I don't know how many people
will come to [INAUDIBLE] now.
So Bedford's approximately
at sea level, about 130 feet
above sea level.
It was minus 4 degrees,
and the density altitude
was minus 1,400.
So we were flying,
you know, skimming
the surface of the
Dead Sea or something
in terms of performance.
So the airplane will be
really happy about flying
all wintertime, and
it'll climb better
than the book, most of
the numbers in the book.
OK, the density
altitude is often
just kind of baked into
the performance chart.
Pipers normally take
off with no flaps.
But if you want to get off
the ground really quickly,
like taking off over
grass or mud or something,
you can put down
the flaps and try
to have less time on
the ground and not be
going so fast over the ground.
Your ground rill
will be shortened.
Anyway, so here,
they don't actually
ask you to ever calculate
the density altitude.
They just say, OK, it's
almost 30 degrees outside.
And it looks like we're up
here at about 1,500 feet.
So we'll start here on
the performance chart.
These people are virtuous.
The only weigh 2,175 total,
so we come down a little bit.
And we can come
over here, and we
find that it's going to take--
is there a wind here--
15 knots of headwind.
So we come down
this graph and we
find that it will
take us 1,500 feet
to take off over a
50 foot obstacle.
Fair enough?
So anyway, we never figured out
what the density altitude was.
It was just something
that affected
where we started on the chart.
I guess, maybe it's
implicit in here.
I think it is implicit, right?
Because we're starting up high.
Maybe somebody who is
smarter can figure this out.
Yeah, so sea level at 0--
Yeah, I think we can pull
it out of those graphs.
But nobody would, because what
you're really interested in
is the number of how long you're
going to be on the runway.
All right, you'll have to slow
down if you're in turbulence.
So if you plan for some kind of
flight a certain amount of time
and it's going to
be very bumpy--
I remember we talked
about maneuvering speed.
Depending on your weight,
you'll have to slow down
to avoid bending the aircraft.
Or, you know, turbulence
that's severe enough
to bend the aircraft
is extremely rare.
But turbulence that's sufficient
to make you and your passengers
unhappy is a lot more common.
And in both cases, you know,
you pull away back on the speed.
So in the Pilatus,
for example, you'll
pull back to 150
knots from 200 knots.
In the Cirrus, you know, you
might pull back from 130 down
to 100.
And in a helicopter,
you know, you'll
pull back from 110
knots to maybe 70.
OK, pilot technique.
So all the book numbers
depend on the pilot
doing what the book says.
So think about
clearing an obstacle
at the end of the runway.
That's dependent on the pilot
rotating within a couple
knots of the specified rotation
speed, getting the gear
and the flaps retracted
if they've been deployed,
or if the gear are retractable
at the recommended airspeed,
and just generally having the
pitch attitude and the air
speeds where the manufacturer
tested the aircraft.
And think about it.
You might say, well, you
know, anybody can do that.
You're rolling down the
runway at Hanscom Field.
It's a mile and a half long.
You know, you're fresh,
so that performance
is-- you're probably going to
come pretty close to the book
performance.
But think about
doing a go-around.
You've just done
a two hour flight.
You were trying to
land at the airport.
You know, somehow, either there
was somebody else on the runway
or, you know, you didn't
get the approach just right,
so you decided you're going
to go around and try again.
At that point, you
know, you've got
to reconfigure the airplane,
change the flap configuration,
change the gear configuration.
There's a couple interesting
incidents that have happened.
Well, it was, unfortunately,
not very interesting
for the people involved.
But there was an
American Airlines flight
that got disoriented in
Colombia in the clouds.
And the terrain warning
system said, you know,
terrain, terrain,
pull up, pull up.
And so they advanced
the thrust levers.
You can follow that
link and read about it.
They advanced the thrust
levers and had maximum power,
but they neglected to-- they
had the spoilers deployed
for a descent.
They didn't retract
the spoilers,
so the airplane was
climbing but not nearly as
well as it would have without
the spoilers retracted.
So that's an example
where, you know,
in a critical situation
or a fatigue situation,
you may not--
I wish I could get this--
I don't know if I can
move this onto the screen.
I want to show a picture of
this crazy airplane that I flew.
Tada!
Look at that Russian seaplane.
It's got two Cirrus
engines in there.
I don't even see
the second engine.
Well, there it is.
You can see that
propeller over there.
So sorry.
There's one propeller
sticking up.
There is the other one.
So it's got two Cirrus engines,
200 horsepower each mounted
on pods.
And if you say, how
can that airplane climb
after an engine failure on
one little Cirrus engine
when it has--
I don't know.
I think it could
seat seven people.
The answer is it really can't.
So I tested that airplane out
because I thought it was cool.
And I went flying with
an airline captain.
And piston twins
aren't really required
to demonstrate any kind
of climb performance.
For jets, there are
certain minimums.
On one engine, it has to
be able to still climb 750
feet per minute or something.
But for these piston twins,
the FAA says, you know,
you should know that
you're buying a pig anyway.
And if you care, go and
get yourself a turbine,
or don't load
everybody in there.
But anyway, this
[INAUDIBLE] thing, it
could not climb on one engine.
We couldn't even maintain
altitude on one engine.
And it turned out
that we'd forgotten
to close the cowl flaps.
It had these extra
openings for cooling
to provide extra cooling
at high power settings.
And if you don't close
them, there's extra drag.
And that extra drag was enough
to turn what should have been,
you know, 150 foot climb rate
or something into 150 foot sink
rate or something.
So that's another thing
that can affect performance.
OK, runway condition.
This really affects
your planning,
whether you can take off,
whether you can land,
how much weight you
can put in there.
So for example,
if it's dry grass,
you need a longer runway
than if it's paved.
Alternatively, you can
take off at a lower weight.
If it's wet grass, you need
a lot more room to land
and, you know, yet
more room to take off.
At the airline,
if the runway was
grooved, which almost all
bigger US airports have
these grooved runways, we
didn't make any adjustments.
Didn't matter how
heavy the rain was.
It didn't matter how
long it had been raining.
We just assumed it was going
to perform exactly the same as
if it were dry.
If it's not a grooved
runway, though,
and water can sit
on the runway, it
can have a big effect
on performance.
So here are some
numbers that I pulled.
I'm type rated in the
Cessna Mustang, which
is an interesting
little business jet.
It lands at about the same
speed as the Beechcraft Baron,
so it's a great beginner jet.
Anyway, so in conditions where
you need 3,000 feet of runway,
that's up at pretty
high altitude,
you're going to need 4,240,
Cessna says, if it's wet.
If water is actually standing on
it, I think 0.1 inches of water
was even more, you'll
need yet more runway.
If it's snow, a little bit more.
Wet ice, it was
just off the chart.
But if you started at
2,200 feet of dry runway,
you would need 16,600 feet.
So actually, oftentimes, when
the surface is contaminated,
that's one reason why
even fairly small business
jets may need a long
runway, like at Logan
or at Hanscom Field.
Even an airport like
Nashua, which has 6,000 feet
may not be enough if they're
reporting that there's
snow on the runway.
OK, what about slope?
So going downhill is obviously
a lot easier than going uphill.
And you can see here-- and
also stopping going uphill
is a lot easier.
So here are some numbers
from the Cirrus book
that every one degree of slope
increases your takeoff run
by 22% at sea
level, for example.
And you also get a 9% reduction
in the landing distance.
OK, ceiling.
The service ceiling
of the aircraft
is a little bit below
the absolute ceiling.
That's where the FAA
says the plane will
climb 100 feet per minute.
The manufacturer has
demonstrated to the FAA
that the airplane could, at
least when it was brand new,
make 100 feet per
minute in climb rate.
So that's 13,500 feet
for a 172 Cessna.
And I think that's pretty
typical for these normally
aspirated four-seaters.
Somewhere around there is
where it'll stop climbing.
The Cirrus, there's
a limitation in there
that says maximum operating
altitude is 17,500 feet.
I think that's more
regulatory, because you
can't take the Cirrus up
into the flight levels.
They need extra equipment to
go up above 18,000 feet, maybe.
I don't think it's really
practical to get up
to 17,500 feet at
maximum gross weight
in the standard atmosphere.
I've gotten into about 13,000
feet out west in the summer,
so that is more like
being at 15,000 feet.
But it was barely climbing.
OK, range versus endurance.
So we're going to get back into
the power and drag curves here.
The max range airspeed is
going to depend on the wind,
like I said earlier.
If you have 100 knot
headwind, then you
have to go faster than 100
knots in order to go anywhere.
If you want to loiter for some
reason-- this year at Oshkosh
was a nightmare for
people who didn't go IFR.
They had a lot of
marginal VFR weather.
So for the first couple of
days, when people were arriving,
there were these short
windows, just an hour or two,
when people could
really get in legally,
the VFR homebuilder types.
So they were just holding.
People were literally
holding for three hours
and then finally had to give
up and go and refuel somewhere.
But if you're in
that situation, you
want to set your speed to
whatever the minimum fuel
consumption speed is.
And it can be quite different.
The Robinson R44 manual talks
about 100 knots for max range.
I believe that's assuming a 10
knot headwind, since usually
we're suffering
with a headwind more
often than with a tailwind.
And you might say,
how is that possible?
How is it possible
to have a headwind--
unless God hates you, how
is it possible to have
a headwind more
than half the time?
If you think about it--
Richard, you know the answer?
RICHARD: I do.
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: What is it?
RICHARD: Here's the question.
You're flying 100
miles to an airport.
In zero wind, how
long does it take
to fly-- you're on an airplane
that flies 100 miles an hour.
How long does it take
to fly round trip?
PHILLIP GREENSPUN:
Trick question.
RICHARD: 100 miles apart,
100 miles an hour airplane,
no wind.
How long is a round
trip going to take?
AUDIENCE: 2 hours?
RICHARD: Yeah.
Let's say you have
a 50 knot headwind.
It's exactly on your nose.
You can get 50 knots
headwind on the way out
and 50 knot tailwind
on the way back.
How long does it take?
AUDIENCE: 2 hours.
RICHARD: Wrong.
Work it out.
PHILLIP GREENSPUN:
Well, that's one aspect.
You're going to spend more of
your time, as Richard's saying.
It's going to take you two hours
to get there in one direction,
and then it won't take
you zero time to get back,
so you're spending more of
your time in the headwind
than in the tailwind.
But there's
something even worse.
I saw this the other
day in the Cirrus.
There was about a 70 knot
wind that was actually
a little bit-- it
should have been
a little bit of a tailwind.
It was more than 90 degrees
off my desired track.
But if you think about
it, the airplane's
constantly having to fight
its way back into that wind,
so it's effectively taking
a longer flight path.
So even the wind is directly
a beam wind 90 degrees off,
there's actually-- the
majority of the circle,
the 360 degrees circle
of wind directions,
the majority of
that is subtracting
from your performance and has at
least some headwind component.
Sound crazy?
Think about it, yeah.
So if you're going 100 miles and
there's also this 100 knot side
wind, you're having
to spend quite
a bit of your energy continuing
to steer into that side wind.
OK, here is a power and
drag curve for an RV-6A.
The experimental guys
are, in this case,
more aggressive about
producing charts.
So if you actually care
about where you're going,
you want to be a little bit
up the power required curve.
You want to find out where it's
tangent to one of these lines
going back to zero.
And if all you care about
is maximum endurance,
you just want to be
at the point where
the curve is at
its bare minimum,
because then you're consuming
the least power and, in theory,
burning the least
amount of fuel.
Does that make sense?
All right, The terms.
Ground roll, these
performance charts
in the book that you
get with the airplane,
they will assume a static start.
So that means you're
holding the brakes,
you slam the power forward,
you let off the brakes,
and you're going to get the
book numbers, because there's
no acceleration
time for the engine.
And actually, that's how jets
are supposed to take off, too.
But you probably remember from
your commercial flights, that's
not really how it happens.
The pilots don't hold the
brakes, you know, spend--
it takes maybe 10 seconds
for a really heavy jet engine
to spool up to full power.
They don't just sit
there holding the brakes,
engine's at the max,
and everything's
screaming in the airplane,
shaking, because it's
just uncomfortable.
So they usually cheat--
technically, they're
not really supposed
to do it because, you know, at
that point, your test pilots.
You don't really have any
data for a rolling takeoff.
But, you know,
again, it would be
kind of unnerving for
passengers, I think,
if they are sitting there
with the airplane straining
against the brakes.
OK, same deal here.
Ground roll and
the total distance
to clear the 50
foot obstacle, this
is what I was telling you about
the other day with the Cirrus
hero who wanted
to go to, I think,
about 2,500 feet of runway.
Actually, we had
to subtract some.
I think it was 2,700 minus 400.
He had about 2,300
feet of runway.
And he wanted to go there in the
Cirrus, which takes 2,100 feet.
Another guy actually
wanted to go to--
there's a private air park
in Falmouth, Massachusetts
where you can have a house
right next to the runway
and keep the airplane
in your garage.
And that airport's
only 2,300 feet long.
And another east
coast aero club guy--
I was handing the
airplane over to him
and he had this huge
friend with him.
This guy was like
a NFL linebacker.
So it was just the
two of them, but big.
And he wanted it also at
full, topped off on fuel,
so they're going to be
right at gross weight.
I said, where are you going?
He said Falmouth.
He'd just gotten his
private pilot certificate
a few months earlier.
This guy was not commercial
IFR rated like the other.
And I said, look, you know,
if you do everything perfect,
you're going to use
up 92% of that runway
because it's hemmed
in by these obstacles.
So don't do it.
So he did end up going
to Hyannis, I think.
All right, landing
technique can actually
affect the performance.
So they talk about, an average
pilot, the book numbers,
they're predicated on
extremely aggressive braking,
like right to the point where
you would flat spot the tires.
So don't count on getting those
book numbers unless you're
willing to be more
aggressive than probably you
would want to be.
And actually, I'll tell you a
story about my airline days.
I did a visual approach
in the Laguardia.
And with jets, it's
not conventional to try
to do the really greaser
landings that you would
do in a little
airplane, because you
need to get the airplane down
and the spoilers to pop up.
The jets are very
efficient gliders.
They don't have a
big prop in front.
And when you pull the power
back on a piston aircraft,
it really slows down
dramatically because the prop
has a lot of air resistance.
None of that's going for
you with the jet which is
more efficient to begin with.
So basically, the task
of an airline pilot
is really to slam it on, and
that way the spoilers pop up
and then the brakes start
really working effectively.
And you turn off the
runway in Laguardia
before you go into the river.
So I landed like a
Cirrus, because it
was my first month on
the job, and I chewed up
by 1,500 feet of runway before
the airplane touched down.
And I applied fairly gentle
braking and thrust reverse
and turned off after about
5,000 feet of runway.
And the captain's
like, that sucked.
I'm going to show you how
it's done the next leg.
So we did Laguardia to
Charlotte, North Carolina.
Who else did that leg?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILLIP GREENSPUN:
Captain Sully.
So he dumped his passengers
into a filthy cold river
and they called him a hero.
I got my passengers to
Charlotte warm and dry,
and where was my medal?
Where is my fame?
Nowhere.
All right, so life is unfair.
You've learned that.
Anyway, so the captain
takes this one.
Air traffic control lines us up.
Instead of the
visual approach where
you're doing everything by eye
and following another aircraft,
and you can't use any
of the fancy automation,
we were lined up 10 or 15 miles
out for a straight in approach
to this angled
runway at Charlotte.
And all the captain had
to do was-- on autopilot,
all he had to do was
tweak the thrust levers
for the perfect airspeed.
The autopilot's flying.
He disconnects the autopilot a
couple feet above the ground.
Now he's hand flying.
All he has to do--
the CRJ doesn't have,
the 50-seater, any
leading edge devices,
so it has to be pointed
down a bit like a lawn dart.
It's not that different
from landing a Cirrus.
It's unconventional
for an airliner.
The airliners, you
notice they usually--
because of the
leading edge devices,
even when they're
going 120 knots or so,
they can be kind of nose up
and they still fly pretty well.
So the airplane
almost can be flown--
and it can auto
land, in some cases,
onto the runway by itself with
just a slight additional flare
at the end.
The CRJ has to be kept nose
down 145 knots faster than all
but the very biggest jets, and
then it has to be, you know,
flared from minus five to
maybe plus five or plus
seven at the end.
So the captain, after telling
me what a bad job I had done,
he flared about
five feet too high,
and the airplane just sailed
over 4,500 feet of runway,
I think, before it
finally touched down.
And he slammed on the brakes,
maximum thrust reverse.
We barely made it off.
I think we made it off
after 7,200 feet of runway,
so we would have been, I think,
in the water in Laguardia.
So that's the kind of thing
where, you know, you can't--
that's why these
safety margins are
good to build into your own
flying, because, you know,
the book number said
the airplane would
land a lot shorter than that.
Also, in a jet, there's really
not a good go-around technique.
Once you're below
50 feet, you're
not supposed to try to
add power and go around
because it takes a while
to spool the engines up.
All right, in
turbulence, you usually
will increase your
approach speed,
which means you're going
to chew up more runway.
You're supposed to add half the
gust factor as a rule of thumb.
So if the wind is 15
gusting 25, you're
going to speed up your
approach by five knots.
And I got the numbers
here for the Cirrus.
75 is kind of a
good overall number,
and then you'll
beef it up to 80.
But that means, unless it
really is a headwind when you're
landing, you're going to
chew up a little more runway
than expected.
OK, flaps, as Tina
mentioned, they
enable you to keep
your approach speed
low while having a nice
steep approach angle.
So that's good for getting
over trees and stuff.
If you're in an aerobatic
airplane or something else that
doesn't have flaps,
you can actually
slip and go sideways
down towards the runway
and get over the obstacles,
but it's a lot easier
just to put the flaps down.
OK, the charts come in all
kinds of variations in the POH,
especially for the
bigger airplanes.
You'll have, you
know, 10 charts that
look identical except
for a couple of numbers,
like the exact flap position,
whether the anti-icing is
on or off.
The Piper Warrior
POH is a lot simpler,
and that's some of
the charts we're
going to cover in addition to
some of the anonymous airplane
charts that the FAA
gives you with the test.
So one thing to remember if
you're a renter, in addition
to the fact that you want to
build in maybe some charter
and airline minimums
into your flying,
is that all those numbers
were with the brand
new airplane that was
perfectly straight
and had a perfect engine.
OK, so wind components.
You're going to get a
shorter takeoff and landing
distances with a headwind.
A tailwind, actually,
it may not be
legal to operate
a high performance
aircraft on a runway
with a tailwind of more
than a certain amount.
I think for the c.r.
It was 10 knots.
We just simply could not land
with a 10 knot tailwind or more
than a 10 knot tailwind.
Crosswind is a
little bit different.
You'll get a max demonstrated
crosswind component
in the manual.
So it'll tell you a
test pilot managed
to hold this airplane straight
on the runway with full flaps,
or whatever the normal landing
configuration is, and there
was enough rudder to land
with a 15 knot crosswind.
So that's max demonstrated.
It's not a limitation.
So if it is, it'll say,
this is a limitation.
But max demonstrated just
means a test pilot did it.
It'll probably work for
you too if you manipulate
the controls in the same way.
And beyond that,
you can't be sure.
So one thing that
people will do is
they will adjust the
flap amount to have--
a reduced use of flaps
in a heavy crosswind,
that keeps the airspeed up.
You will chew up more runway.
But when the wheels
actually touch the ground,
the wheels provide a little
bit of stabilization and help
keep you from getting
blown off the runway.
You're going to see tomorrow
Dojo from the Brazilian Air
Force is going to tell you about
testing the various airplanes,
but especially the Super Tucano,
in very heavy crosswinds down
there in South America.
They have some
pretty heavy winds.
I think they went
to Chile to do that.
I could be wrong.
Or maybe it was just right
next to the Andes in Brazil.
OK, crosswind chart.
So this here shows you that, if
you have a 40 knot wind at a 30
degree angle, you go over here
on the chart to the 30 degree
line, you use this 40
knot ring, and then
you can find that it's a 35
knot headwind and a 20 knot
crosswind.
Does that make sense?
I will tell you when
I was getting a type
rating for this Cessna
Mustang flight safety,
there were a couple of
Boeing 737 pilots there,
and they had no idea
how to use this chart.
And they couldn't even
give the right answers.
If you said, you know,
you're landing on runway 27
and the wind's coming
from 315, is that
a tailwind or a headwind?
And they couldn't answer
that question either.
Basically, all they do is
go from towered airport
to towered airport.
The tower tells them
what runway to use.
They are from the
Philippines, so I
guess it's not
insanely windy there
like it would be in Argentina.
I once landed in
Argentina in Ushuaia
on a commercial airline
flight, and it was 50 knot--
the wind was, I
think, 35 gusting 50.
And the pilots, you know, I
talked to them afterwards.
They said it was
just a normal day.
They wouldn't even bother
talking about that.
So anyway, these
skills apparently rest.
I'm sure those guys, you know,
had used a chart like that
at one point in their training.
They did get their type
rating, so the good news
is you can get your type
rating without knowing
how to use that.
OK, here's one of
the FAA charts.
This is what they
give you on the test.
It's a lot easier
to use than the POH.
Here's a problem.
They're giving you
an example problem.
Let's see.
We're at somewhere in Colorado,
apparently 5,650 feet.
We weigh 2,950 pounds
in this airplane
that they won't
tell us what it is.
It's nine knots of headwind.
Notice these
associated conditions.
These are really critical.
And again, if they give you
a choice of multiple charts,
that's where the trick is.
You know, they're trying to
get you to use the wrong chart.
That's more on the AP exam
than on the private one.
But yeah, see here, powerful
throttle, cowl flaps are open.
This is some kind of
more complicated plane,
that you got the right mixture
set even before you take off
for high altitude.
All right, so what
do we got here?
We got temperature of 15.
We go up to the air
pressure altitude,
pretty close to 6,000.
We come over here,
we're apparently
right at gross weight, so
at least that's realistic.
Most aircraft take off right at
gross weight for most flights.
There's nine knots
of wind, so that's
going to subtract a little bit
from our runway requirements.
And here we can see it's
1,500 feet of ground roll
and a little over--
what is that, 2,300?
Yeah, 2,300 to clear
the 50 foot obstacle.
So these charts are
not hard to use.
And in the real world,
maybe in the FAA figure,
they actually give
you this example.
So you can see how it's
done and then, you know,
you just draw the lines
in a different place.
So they're not
trying to trick you.
Here's a chart for
the Pilatus PC-12.
There's also apps
to do it, which
I'll show you a
little bit later,
similar to that Piper
chart we saw earlier
where you calculate the density
altitude without realizing
that you've calculated it.
Yeah, so here you've
got pressure altitude
and temperature, and
you're implicitly
calculating density altitude.
Then you go over to weight.
Look at this one.
The Pilatus guys, I think
they are having some fun here.
They're saying you're
taking off at 7,000 pounds.
So you're missing almost 3,000
pounds of people and bags.
You paid all this
money for this airplane
and you're barely using it.
So I don't think that happens
too often unless you've just
dropped everybody off at
an airport with no fuel
and you're repositioning.
Anyway, so you've
got the headwind.
They've got uphill and downhill
all baked into this nice chart.
You can get all
these good numbers.
This is why Cirrus is better,
why they're the best seller.
They just say, look,
here is this table.
There's a few
corrections that you
can use if you want to up
there in the upper right
for headwind, tailwind, grass.
But basically, they make
the usual case very simple
of a level runway,
a paved runway.
It's always more
conservative to go more.
You know, you don't
have to interpolate.
You can just say,
well, it's 25 degrees,
so I'll use the
30 degree number.
OK, what is the
rate of climb here?
We're in a gross
weight of 1,670 pounds.
It's 2,000 feet.
How do we figure that out?
This is one of the
FAA example tables,
and it's as simple as finding
the right row in the table, row
and column in the table.
Or actually, have a look here.
So they're saying
the mixture has to be
lean to get these numbers.
The flaps have to be up.
You've got to be
at full throttle.
OK, same deal,
max rate of climb.
I forget if this a--
this might be a
paper chart, but you
can see that associated
conditions up there
in the top left.
That's absolutely critical.
You know, The gross weight--
Cirrus, actually, a lot
of the performance numbers
in the Cirrus for cruise
speed are at 2,600 pounds
and you're flying along at 2,950
because you took off at 3,000.
You're wondering, how come
I'm not getting these numbers?
But of course, you know,
they're being optimistic about--
they're putting their
airplane in the best light
by positing some
weight that probably
doesn't exist in real life.
All right, here they give us an
example of 5,000 feet pressure
altitude, OAT of 16 degrees, so
ISA plus 11, max rate of climb,
374.
So I guess, yeah, 5,000 feet.
Here's ISA plus 11.
It says 376 with some kind
of elaborate interpolation.
I guess you find that last
couple feet per minute
that you subtract.
Here's cruise charts.
I think, again, this is from
the FAA test supplement.
They're just giving
you-- remember I told you
it would be ISA minus 20?
That's the chart on the left.
The one in the middle
is the standard day.
And on the right is a
summer day, ISA plus 20.
Notice that they'll give you
fuel flow and the true airspeed
given various engine speed and
manifold pressure settings.
This looks like it's
for a piston twin.
OK, landing performance is a
pretty similar kind of chart.
Not going to go
through this exactly,
but you can see they're
giving you the worked example.
And you come up with--
let's see.
It's going to be about a little
over 1,000 feet of ground
roll and 1,700 feet, they claim,
to clear a 50 foot obstacle.
Here's an FAA
question, actually.
So let's see.
Determine the total distance
required for takeoff
to clear a 50 foot obstacle.
Standard temperature, sea level.
So actually, this
is testing you.
This is pretty advanced, right?
They're saying it's the standard
temperature at sea level,
so you have to know
that it's 15 degrees.
We only weigh 2,700
pounds, so we're
going to have to ride down
this curve a little bit.
And the wind's
calm, so we're not
going to get any
boost from the wind.
So what do you guys think?
Have any of you been
able to kind of see
what the most likely number
is by following these?
Somebody says A?
Let's see.
It's a little bit lighter.
That kind of makes sense.
But on the other
hand, the wind's
calm, so we didn't get that
reduction from the wind.
Let's see.
So if we came down
here, it's going
to start from sea
level, 15 degrees.
Come over here.
Come down here over
a 50 foot obstacle,
then we have to go up.
Anybody want to
revise their estimate?
A, we heard A last time.
It seems a little short to
clear the 50 foot obstacle.
I agree with you that you'd
be well off the ground
by 1,000 feet.
Tada!
All right, obviously,
you know, if you
have a pencil and a little more
time to do that, it's easier.
That's kind of the hard way.
Let's look at the easy way.
Getting the runway numbers
for low performance aircraft,
it actually remains pretty
common to just use the POH.
People aren't usually
in a situation
where they have
to worry about it.
If you're going from Hanscom
Field or Martha's Vineyard
and back, you
know, both airports
are big enough for a
Boeing, and you're not
going to be carefully
calculating these numbers
unless you really don't
have much else to do.
Apps, though, are available even
for low performance aircraft,
and they're very
useful if you're going,
you know, into tighter
airports And you
might have to worry about that.
The time and fuel
stuff is everywhere
on the web and the apps.
But the actual runway numbers
are a little bit less common.
Let me show you a
couple of things.
Here's Gyronimo.
So they sell these for
different aircraft.
This is just off their website.
And for an SR22, you
can see you put in--
they must be European.
They say aircraft mass 3,359.
And you've got your temperature,
your takeoff elevation,
your altimeter,
runway conditions.
I don't know what
that plus 5% is.
Maybe they're saying-- oh, I
don't know if that's between--
is it half grass and half paved?
Anyway, you can put
in everything relevant
and it's going to tell
you how much ground roll
and how much takeoff distance.
So that's pretty slick.
It's a lot easier than
relying on the POH.
The calculator for
the Pilatus is free.
That's the good news.
And here, same deal.
You put in your weight,
the temperature,
if there's any headwind,
the airport elevation,
and you get the numbers.
All right, we can try to
get the doc camera working
for a demo in a minute here.
But in the meantime, first
of all, are there questions?
And secondly, what
is this aircraft?
And what's it designed for?
AUDIENCE: Question
about the test.
Will it be on the
[INAUDIBLE] for this class?
Because it's online, right?
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: Yeah.
Well, you can print out
the test supplement.
That's public.
It's in our Dropbox.
And also, the FAA makes this
chart supplement public,
so you can see all the
figures that you're
going to see before the test.
I think, actually, when
you're done with your test,
I think you can print
out all the questions
and it'll show you
what you got right.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because for the grass, this
is going to be harder for me
to [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: Oh, yeah.
Yeah, just print out the chart.
Yeah, sure, another
chart supplement.
Anybody have any brilliant
ideas about this aircraft?
It says Grizz on it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: That's a
Burt Rutan design, the climate
change denier.
And this is a super
short field airplane.
It actually doesn't land as
short as you might think.
I think it might be a
four-seater, though,
so I guess it is pretty darn
short for a four-seater.
But it has huge flaps
and a lot of wing area,
and it's got that--
I think it has ordinary--
Yeah, see, it has essentially
three surfaces right?
It's got kind of a
helper wing or a canard
out in front, the
regular wing, and then
an ordinary
conventional tail plane.
Let me see if I can get
this doc camera working.
All right, so let's say we want
to know how much fuel we're
going to use.
See that fuel pounds there?
Where is that?
Somewhere along here--
well, actually, I
happen to know it's got to be
somewhere-- we're 10 pounds.
Yeah, see, there's US
gallons right there.
So we line this up.
And you can tell this was
designed for piston folks,
because their idea
of fuel weight
is six pounds per gallon,
and jet fuel weighs 6.7.
But at this point, now we've
got our handy slide rule.
So we know, if we load on, for
example, 10 gallons of fuel,
it's going to be 60 pounds.
And the Cirrus holds
56 gallons, so that's
going to weigh 300 and--
looks like 345.
Oh, sorry, 335 gallons.
335 pounds.
More to the point, you can
calculate density altitude.
So over here, for
example, you can
say the pressure altitude is--
let's call it sea level.
And it's very hot, though.
It's plus 40 degrees.
So now you see the
density altitude up there
is about 2,000 feet.
Does that make sense?
So you've set the pressure
altitude at the bottom
or inside this little
window at zero,
and then the density
altitude gets read out here
after you line it up
with a temperature.
There's also something
that you can do, well,
just with the basic rate.
So let's say you decide that
you're going to be going--
this is more for
performance planning.
But let's say you're a Cirrus
and you're going 150 knots.
If you end up needing to go,
let's say, 300 nautical miles,
it tells you that'll
take you two hours.
Not too exciting, but the wind
side is a little more exciting.
I'll bring a pencil tomorrow
for the flight planning talk
and we can play around
with wind vectors on there.
But anyway, fortunately,
a lot of this stuff
is explained in the book.
You guys are free to come up
and play around with it anytime.
There's a temperature conversion
scale here on the bottom.
And it's a fun toy.
Tina, anything else that
we should cover here?
Or should be segue?
What's the next--
TINA SRIVASTAVA: So we're
going to take questions,
and then there's a short
break, and then weather data.
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: OK, the
next one's weather data.
You'll need a
break for that one.
That's how you find
out all this stuff.
Let me go back to the PC.
Who else has questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you
go [INAUDIBLE]??
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: Go back
over and look at a POH graph?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: Which one?
You want to do with
the FAA exam ones?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the last one.
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: Lane
landing performance,
or this one from
the actual test?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: OK,
so I don't think they
ever give it worked out for you.
Let me switch to the
laser pointer mode.
OK, so what do they tell us?
They told us it was
standard and sea level.
That's the one part of
the standard atmosphere
that people, I think,
are expected to remember,
that at sea level it should
be 15 degrees Celsius.
So we come down here.
We say it's 15 degrees out.
We're going to hit the sea
level pressure altitude.
We're going to slide over this
way, just like in the example.
And then we're going to slide
down, following this curve,
to 2,700 pounds.
And we're going to go
over here, and we're going
to say, look, there's no wind.
The wind's calm, so we'll
keep going over here,
and we find that we need about
a little less than 1,000 feet,
maybe 800 feet,
for a ground roll.
But to clear the 50 foot
obstacle, look at the bottom
there.
We need to go up, following
one of these lines,
and that's how we get
to the 1,400 number.
Did that help?
You still look a
little bit skeptical.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it just doesn't
look like that line [INAUDIBLE]
PHILLIP GREENSPUN:
Well, remember, we
would be doing this
with a virtual pencil.
These lines are
just for reference,
telling you kind of what slope
to follow with your pencil.
So it's not like these are
the only available points.
So it's not like it's going to
be either this for the answer,
or this for the answer,
or this for your answer.
Even in their
worked example, you
can see their red line for
the answer is just parallel
to that gray line.
They're not picking
one of the gray lines.
So they're guidelines
for how you should
move your pencil in each phase.
I hope this motivates you
to buy that Gyronimo app.
It certainly would
motivate me to do it.
TINA SRIVASTAVA: If you want
to look at it on a real book,
I'll pass around-- again,
this is my POH for Cessna 172.
So this might be
the type of plane
that you're using as
your training aircraft.
And I have a couple
of pages that are
marked with a piece of paper.
So one talks about how you
calculate the takeoff distance.
And one is weight and balance.
We'll actually have a
whole section dedicated
to weight and balance.
But just to give
you a sense of how
you can follow with your
pencil, and you'll actually
see some pencil markings
of my own fairly
close to the limits here of
our center of gravity moment
envelope here, but
still within the box,
so just to give you an
idea of how you can do that
with a real paper and pencil.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] So within that
[INAUDIBLE] Is that the reason?
PHILLIP GREENSPUN: Yeah.
So the question is, you know, we
don't have any kind of readout
in the aircraft for
density altitude.
So is that why we're always
calculating with our handy E6B
or listening to the
ASOS or whatever?
So, yeah.
Yeah, basically your
instruments in the aircraft
can tell you the temperature,
outside air temperature,
maybe not quite as accurate
as the one from the airport
if you're on the ground.
And they can also show you,
if you set your altimeter
to two niner niner two, you
can see the pressure altitude.
But the relationship between
the two is not simple.
And there's nothing onboard
the aircraft conventionally
that will calculate it for you.
And I don't think
that's quite true.
I think a lot of
modern GPS boxes
will do that
calculation for you.
But you have to type
in all the numbers.
They don't usually just grab it.
They will give you things
like true air speed.
They'll definitely
calculate that.
So if you're indicating 150
but you're up really high,
they'll tell you,
well, now you're
going 200 knots
in true air speed,
and then they'll give you
your ground speed, too.
And they'll even show
you with a wind vector.
TINA SRIVASTAVA:
Any other questions?
OK, great.
So we'll just take
a 10 minute break
and start up again at
2:15 with weather data.
And that's the one you guys
seem to keep asking about,
so we'll talk about
also, towards the end
of that talk, how you build
your own ADS-B receiver.